what's her name again that i'm always
beefing with yeah what's her name come
on
you just said her no you don't know
you don't know because i don't say her
name so like so then there
so let's just go ahead and give it
no well even that thing of not being
authentic
is fascinating
[Music]
hey everybody welcome to another episode
of hot boxing i'm evan britton and i'm
mike tyson
mike we've got like i was saying earlier
we've got a strong powerful female in
the house
big time that's awesome
and your husband and my husband is in
the building he's busy
tammy roman welcome thank you thank you
for having me
it's a pleasure thank you absolutely
it's a pleasure having you here
um you know we are we are big
big fans of the divine feminine and the
rising
feminine uh consciousness in our
society and the ethos of the world so
it's great to have you here and
bring that perspective into the hot
button let's do it
so let's just let's just go back to the
beginning
where where are you from i'm originally
from white plains new york
another white plains is that yes white
plains up your way
yeah way back when
[Laughter]
that's awesome yeah and you grew up in
new york grew up on the east coast
i grew up well i was born in mount
vernon raised in white plains left new
york when i was 15 years old my mom
moved to california
and then i ended up in long beach so
went to long beach poly with some of
your other friends snoop and orangey
you went to school with those wow
yes that's so interesting too i know i
saw that
well how what was that like back in the
day i mean uh
you know coming from new york to
california is always a culture shock no
matter what
yeah but uh you know everybody was very
receptive to me you know like long beach
was a good
place back then and it was a good time
you know what i mean like it was
the freaking late 80s 90s like i feel
like those were the best years of my
life
yeah absolutely renaissance of hip-hop
yeah best time yeah it was so good in
the 90s you know
and then um you know kind of finished
school here
in california and then uh started
working
at an hiv health care center you know
back in the early 90s when you know
we didn't know what was going on and
what would make you want to work there
because i have this maternal nature
about myself
where it was just like you know seeing
so many of my friends easy e
you know had passed from it at the time
and i was like
i want to find out more and i want to do
more and i want to help more and i want
to be a part of the movement
i know girl i worked in the senate she
said it was so depressing
it well see that's why i ended up
leaving was because
um i was running like the drug program
there at the time i was like the vice
president of the
drug program and um you know you're
passing out meds one week
and then they're supposed to show up for
their appointment the next
and then you hear that they pass so
eventually
at that age i was 23 and i was like
this is too much yeah this is too much
family my friend is
really heavy to the press yeah it was a
lot you know
in that center what was the mindset like
what did people
think was happening dude i you know at
that time here again this was 92-93 so
people didn't really know what was
happening you know people we
didn't really have a gauge 10 years old
now
at that time it was probably 10 years
old and still they had no idea
we still had no idea you know like our
greatest references particularly for the
african-american culture were
magic and then easy
you know and uh we couldn't really
figure out
you know is this something that's going
to take us down or are we going to be
like you know magic and survive this
thing and but we really had no knowledge
we really had no education
on the disease so it was really really
new
um but here again i couldn't stay i
couldn't stay
you know my intent was
right with my heart but my emotional
well-being was suffering
from staying in that environment oh i
believe it yeah
but from you know something good came
out of it because uh i got on
the real world which was the very next
yeah i think
it's there yeah yeah um
well one of my co-workers had actually
auditioned
for the real world i didn't know what it
was and um
she came in my office she was like i
didn't make it on this show and
you know i'm so bummed and i was like
what show and she's like the real world
had never heard of it i was like oh girl
you'll be fine
see you monday this is at the center
this is at the center oh my god
and so uh go home that weekend and mtv
was doing a marathon of the real world
and i sat there and watched it and then
i told my mom about it i was like you
audition for something like this [ __ ]
you know i'll try that [ __ ]
and so we went to the mall uh burbank
mall
and she filmed me like we had the
[ __ ]
video camera that had the tape on the
side i don't know if anybody remembers
them [ __ ] so i'm not even talking about
the little one i'm talking about the
real vhs tape
so uh we walked around the burbank mall
are you too young for that moment i i
came in on the tail end yeah we were
moving we were transitioning to the
little small
small ones okay well i was around for
the big joint
and uh we walked around the mall and she
taped me and then that monday
i called out from the healthcare center
and went to
mtv's offices to take them my tape wow
and uh they were like get the hell out
we're not you know that's not how it
works
type of thing and i'm like no you're
going to look at my tape and uh i called
such a ruckus in the lobby that the
casting director came out was like okay
fine
i will look at it so she watched it for
like five minutes and like are you
satisfied and i was like yeah you know
and then a week later they called me and
said uh we'd like to offer you
the slot on the show that's so so you
know history
proves itself that destiny is strong
no it's perseverance and will you yeah
you refuse to be turned down yeah refuse
to tell them
you would see it later you wanted them
to see it i wanted them to watch my tape
now i don't you know i don't know if she
watched anymore after that five minutes
but i feel like it was more the
impression that i left on her
yeah that i was like you guys gotta look
at this girl you gotta you know take
notice
hell yeah so yeah i love that this is
not how that
how it works here not how it works
yes it is because i think that's true
with anything right yeah one day i was
just looking when his audio books was on
today and i was looking at um there's
[ __ ] laws of power right and then
you're talking about you have to
distinguish yourself from everybody else
and be noticed
this is true that's one of the laws of
power to be distinguished without
offending anybody to be noticed i'll
shine everyone else but the master but
the master i was going to say i was
going to piggyback you and say and
there's also something in there that
talks about
master slave number one master slave
that's the number one yeah
don't outshine the master yeah number
one
yeah yeah and recognizing which role you
play
in the dynamic and understanding that
thought process
you know what i mean some because
sometimes you're the master yeah you
know what i mean
what is this book 48 laws of power bobby
green this
it talks about dick takes about what
happens in history and they explain what
what could happen if it does if it fails
if you do the wrong [ __ ] you know it's
just an awesome book
great for entertainment that's all yeah
you should read that one it'll be good
yeah it'll be good
so what was that like the real world
that's sort of
the that is sort of the scene
but we didn't even know what the hell it
was because it wasn't a
thing you know like now when you talk
about reality tv is like do you really
want to do that you know what i mean but
then it was like [ __ ] i get to live at
the beach
you guys are going to pay me this is
real world la this is real world delays
wow yeah so i was like i'll do that
because i'm trying to leave here anyway
so let me move on to my next gig you
know so it was one of those moments and
uh moving into the house with you know
the six
other people was new because real world
was supposed to be a soap opera
it was developed by mary ellis bunnum
and john murray
and they didn't have the budget to hire
actors
so they said well let's do the same
concept and just put real people in it
and so history was born by way of the
the first installment in new york whoa
people are interesting to watch yeah
very well everybody's voyeurs by nature
yeah
you know what i mean i'm glad you said
yeah they really i never understood why
do i care about
these people because i do care right
right
why do i care about the [ __ ]
kardashians but i do care about them
and they do make me look at them yeah
but you know why you look because it's
sometimes it's a [ __ ] train wreck and
you're you're like sometimes [ __ ] in
your life is so [ __ ] up you're like
let me see
who else is [ __ ] up yeah because
somebody else has to be going through
something
you don't care what racing yeah he's
done that before oh [ __ ]
yeah this [ __ ] said she said that and
you can't believe they said you heard
that's one of your secrets
yeah yeah that's one of your big secrets
and somebody said until the holy spirit
it's therapeutic
it it yeah in a weird way in a weird way
yeah
no there's nothing weird about it it's
people and this is what i do right
it's a reflection exactly exactly
exactly um well that was sort of the
the launching pad yeah and even though i
think
in our culture it was sort of the
original social media in a way
um i wouldn't say it was the original
social media what i would say
it is that it was the pioneer of a genre
that opened up real people for for just
just what we just said to be able to
look into the greatest things ever made
reality shows one of the greatest things
in mankind the history ever made reality
shows
wow it's crazy though the real world
because this is what we avoid that's
what we do all our life avoiding
the majority of 99 of us through our
whole life avoiding ourselves
yeah true and we see ourselves then you
see yourself sometimes we accept it we
don't like ourselves
we're constantly trying to improve
ourselves you know what i mean why why
do we constantly try to improve
ourselves
why tell me why do we do that we look
we're growing old we're going to die
why don't we constantly improve
ourselves because because there's
something to be said about evolvement so
when you say why are we constantly
trying to
improve ourselves i think that also is a
humanistic nature of people just like
not just humans animals they're
constantly trying to improve and tell me
why some people it's homeless and no
matter how much money you give them they
won't take unless it's right there
this is what i want to do i don't want
to be helped this is what i want to do
well doesn't that speak to what you just
said earlier which was
your drive and your tenacity if you
don't have the will to want to do
something
else i think it's innate i think
there it's a it is one time had that
tenacity you know how do they how do you
how do you lose that
well the universe is constantly
expanding
and we are a microcosm of the universe
and so and like you're saying everything
is constantly in motion
and progressing and moving to the next
thing
and so it's it really is it's an innate
characteristic of being human where
you're constantly striving to
be better in a way
but to speak to your point you said why
do people lose that because sometimes
life knocks you down so much
or to a point that you even though you
have that drive you don't actually know
how to recover
and some people you know like even you
know to speak to my personal situation
i used to be married to a professional
athlete kenny anderson
and we got divorced and um you know
there was a point in my life where it
was really hard for me like a year and a
half of my life it was really hard for
me
now i could have been the type of person
of like all right well this is just kind
of what it is and go back to work in a
regular job and stay complacent and
in that moment but there was something
inside of me that was like
that's you know you don't work at a
health care center and
end up on tv that's not how it goes so i
felt like my destiny was something
bigger was there was a bigger purpose
so i could have said all right this is
how it is you know i'm on ebt
you know i'm just gonna live my life
like this with my kids in this little
three bedroom house
or do i understand what my destiny is
do i still have the drive that i had
when i was 19 20 21
to want something more for myself and so
i went out to get it
so what do you call that do you call
what do you call that energy right there
what do you call it do you call it
common sense or you call that your ego
or do you call it determine what do you
call that
i would i would like to think it's
determination
i would like to think it's tenacity i
would like to think it's perseverance
um rather than defeat having a defeatist
attitude you know what i mean
um and it's not a common sense thing
because common sense implies that we all
know how to do it like we should know
how to do it
and sometimes that's not a person's
upbringing that's not a person's
character that's not
that's not how they were developed from
a child
so they don't so it's not a common sense
thing they some people don't know
but for me in particular you know my mom
worked three jobs so all i saw was some
my role model was somebody who got up
and worked
and no matter what was going on in our
lives she was gonna get it
and so for me it would be you know
diminishing the legacy for of her and
honoring of her
to just be complacent with a situation
that was
negative with a situation that was
belittling with a situation that was
less than what i am actually here to do
so i had to go get it in a nutshell
yeah yeah that's a great articulation of
that
i don't know that mechanism of our of
our
psyche because it's not you know it's
you're right it's
not common no you know it's not
something that everybody has
not everybody has that you know people
get crushed by they get crushed by life
like really and truly let me tell you
something if i told you old [ __ ] that i
have gone through
i i really should have jumped off the
gwb like real talk
but you know i'm just not i don't look
at things
as um
they're gonna take me down i've been
homeless i've been molested i've been
raped i've been you know like all of
those things have been
in the history of my life's journey now
somebody else would not have
been able to survive mentally i'm not
talking about physically they're still
here
but i'm talking about mentally but for
me it was a matter of you know i've been
in an abusive relationship i've been
you know like it's it's the gamut of
everything that i've experienced in my
life
and a lesser person would not be here
but for me
i try to look at everything as a lesson
because that's the way i was brought up
you know what is the lesson in this what
am i supposed to learn what could i be
doing
what could i have done differently in
that situation so that would not have
been the situation
and just evolving from those thought
processes
and it wasn't something that happened
overnight it's just something that
innately i i was doing because of my
upbringing
and then now that i'm older i understand
how to really put the thought
into action and really take those
thought processes
and move them around for the benefit of
me
yeah so what was that like
on the real world oh um you know it was
a long time
what do you remember from that yeah what
do you like what were the sort of
things that you really learned in that i
remembered from that environment
how to be adaptable because
you take people who probably wouldn't
talk to each other you know
probably would not be able to co-exist
or
never have and you put them in this
closed
space and and that really taught me how
to
um you know just adjust and re-reassess
situations that normally i would not
have been privy to
to be able to make some you know some
good friends and some good memories and
some good moments
rather are you still in touch with some
people i only talked to three people
from the show
stupid white wasn't the name spunk punks
well puck came
after me he was season three he was
season three
yeah and he came after me but um
yeah i i still talk to at least three of
them now it's not every day we got on
the phone every day
but you know we can have a conversation
if we see catch up every once in a while
yeah tell us about the housewives
basketball wise that's the real [ __ ]
you weren't gonna let me make it huh you
ain't gonna let me make it
would you want to know because i mean
it's so much i've been doing that show
for nine years brilliant [ __ ]
what was after so when did that hold on
no you got to think about this yeah yeah
there's no
[ __ ] that um what was the first year of
that
of basketball uh the first year for me
was 2010 the first year for the show was
2009.
okay yeah yeah uh so that's it's more of
the same
i mean like nobody's reinventing the
wheel they're just adding their spokes
right now i am yeah i am tired
nine years and they got you as the bad
[ __ ] now for nine years
you gotta change your relations you
gotta change your image before you get
off the show
i i have uh
i have diligently been working on
using reality tv as a mirror
to see when things haven't been
you know up to par or how i know they
how i should act in certain moments
and re adjusting they got in the shoe
you being a queen a nice person you
leave but loving your heart
well i have i i've always had love in my
heart that's how the image has to be
they can't leave you off
you're on screen yeah no i'm pretty i'm
pretty good because you know
it took me nine years to get to a point
of realizing that
you know an idiot is the person who gets
up doing the exact same thing thinking
it's going to be a different outcome
and so certain relationships and
dynamics on the show
always no matter what we did that's not
an idiot that's a crazy [ __ ]
that's crazy [ __ ]
real talk keep doing the same [ __ ] we're
gonna
you know so it took me nine years to
figure out this [ __ ] is not gonna be
different
and so i had to implement some you know
some conditions for myself
to be able to yeah yeah life
tools of life yes yes in order to be
able to stay there this long
but you know this is my my last year
with that particular franchise
what do you think you want to do after
that you know i like reality tv
so you know it's not that i'm going away
from reality tv i'm entering in
back into more scripted programming
potentially do another reality show just
not with that
that set of ladies and then producing
content
you know to give people opportunities
did some of the girls are you guys
some of the guys that you were friends
with are you not friends with them now
because of the show
are you talking about the people on the
show yes
i would think come on let's get some
money we can make some money doing this
[ __ ] not in our friends
you would you would think you would
think that you could make money you know
what i mean because at the end of the
day were co-workers and you hope to
build a friendship you know you hope to
have some camaraderie there
but you know sometimes people don't have
that mindset
you know and so when people don't have
the same mindset as you're not
like-minded if you're not equally yoked
in that sense then it's not going to
work no matter
talk what the the vulnerability you have
to be willing to
show being on reality tv
that is the only way that you're going
to make it in reality tv and i think
now that the genre has expanded and
people
see so much content in the reality space
they recognize when some [ __ ] is fake
they recognize when you put no one for
the camera
i'm loving hip-hop sometimes getting
[ __ ] scripted fake [ __ ]
nobody can't be that man you can't be
mad for that long long
exactly you man for more than three
minutes you faking or it's not that deep
you know what i'm saying for you to be
you know running across the room and
throwing anything
off the table right exactly the
bodyguard the plants just
it's not that moment and i think for me
that's what has kept me
in the genre since 93 to now is that
level of authenticity and genuineness
i never sugarcoat anything that i'm
going through in my life i never put on
airs
i never you know like i'm an open book
with that because i feel like let me
tell my [ __ ] because
somebody find out some [ __ ] about you
then they running now with social media
they run into the blogs and trying to
plant stories and all [ __ ] i'm telling
[ __ ] myself
that way y'all can't use it against me
and so that's always been my thought
process
all the way through from real world to
now yeah
it seems like you just have to be you
have to be willing to just be totally
open
yeah yeah have you been on the show yes
he has
how's that for you man
man really it's it's not my thing yeah
you know i'm more of a low-key and a bad
guy
you know do my thing and stay out the
way but um
whatever babe needs you know i'm not
ever getting a little upset that you see
it going through [ __ ] on the show
all the time really i would think so be
one to do some [ __ ]
what do you do man actually i'm a online
entrepreneur i have a couple online
businesses
sweet e-commerce and also flip real
estate back in houston
awesome man you're from houston yep from
how do you guys meet each other so far
away oh man
one day a friend of mine and now we went
out to eat we was hungry
so we stopped at a spot called papa dogs
oh yeah
so you know we pull up and uh we see her
and her friend
walking in right so my partner you know
he's a dog he's gone
he wants everything so he talking to her
friend or whatever
so long story show we end up coming in
and we we were trying to be seated
she's seeing me again like okay he's 6'5
he chocolate
this is what she's this is what she's
saying this is what she's saying
say you guys come sit over here so you
know i'm like
cool so we sit down you know we just
eat talk mingle hit it off hit it off
man
and later that night we met up talked
for like three four hours just
talk that's awesome
been like that ever since bro i love it
so i don't know man
it's just a great story that's perfect
yeah
so if you want to give your version i
mean that was that was good enough i
thought you
yeah that was good that was solid yeah
it was it was a solid
you know rendition guy explanation yeah
yeah it's the guy explanation i was
talking to my wife today
this morning we got up this morning
probably four
months a day why do you think um people
are meant to be together
like why me together you know what i
mean what is it why why are we still
together we you know we don't
we're just together we just don't leave
each other we call the [ __ ] we don't
say we don't do nothing yes together
we're together we finish each other's
sentences
we're just together why do you think
it's like that
you know what i mean then we get older
we die together
and what did she say uh what'd she say i
had no idea
you know but she said this meant to be
she said she said that we lived many
lives together that's why
yeah she believed that we lived many
lives together i said what happened to
my otherwise my other girlfriends
do you think they think the same thing
you know
what what happened what happened to them
what happened to one night standing and
all those good what do they mean in my
life
what was that all about what are your
people you've been what did they mean in
your life
why did we have to go do that to be here
well
well i think you go through that because
all a lot of us don't recognize when you
get that
that right moment when the universe has
aligned all of the
forces for you to be with the person
that you're supposed to be with
now if you're some people somebody the
first person they met there with them
for the rest of their life
but but it's not like they but it's not
like they haven't had experiences no i'm
talking about some people know they just
met the first time these guys we met
each other and
we died together yeah i'm like teenagers
yeah there's
there's things like that there there are
things like that but here again
they still had experiences before they
before they got together i'm not
particularly talking about experiences
in other relationships i'm talking about
life experiences where once they got
together they were able to recognize
this is this is the fit
some of us aren't you know we don't have
that moment so you go through the
one-night stands i had to go through the
kenny anderson i had to go through the
other people
so that now i have testimony when i meet
the person that
is really supposed to be my fit my
person
i'm able to recognize that
because if you have challenges if you
have arguments if you have
disagreements if you have all of that
[ __ ] not saying that that's not in
relationships but i'm talking about the
minute you meet somebody and you see
like this [ __ ] is tumultuous
that's not your fit but you needed to
experience that so that once you got
with your fit
you knew how to recognize it that's what
i think i i don't think anything is not
without purpose
absolutely i had this dream whoa lord
that started when i was seven years old
and the dream was i was chasing this
girl
through an arcade in a tent
okay and she would i was never quite
able to catch her and she would run out
of the tent
into this green meadow and by the time i
got out there she was
already in a carriage like gone
i don't know i was just in love with her
and i had this recurring dream
and when i was 17 and i got to the
university of arizona
i saw my future wife
there at this student orientation this
athlete orientation
and the same energy of that girl from my
dream dream
was in and she wouldn't date me
i was in love with her i was like this
is the girl from my dream
there was that and she didn't want
anything to do with the football
parts yeah so it took years before she
actually went on a date with me and then
we were inseparable from then on
and um you know i don't know if it's
like that for everybody
and but it's just you know it's like
like you were saying right like we were
meant to be together our spirits were
entangled and
the more i go through life i think about
how we were together in past lives
and you know our life now is about
rectifying things that happened in past
lives and unwinding trauma and
pain and coming into love and light yes
and you know i mean our relationships
are cosmic man they're spiritual
yeah when it works when it's good and it
can be hell
yeah you know it can be i mean
relationships can just be hell you know
true true so no it's a fascinating thing
you know we could talk foreign yeah yeah
absolutely
but you're on a new show tails uh
tails i was a guest star on tv guest
star
uh my latest show is called saints and
sinners
okay and that's on bounce that is with
vanessa bell callaway keith robinson
clifton powell
and uh another show called are you
sleeping with octavia spencer
and michael beach uh executive produced
by reese witherspoon
so sweet yeah that's awesome yep
i'm excited what's saints and sinners
about saints and sinners is about the
black church
wow and all the shenanigans that really
happened
behind the scenes of the of the black
church
interesting yeah what's so interesting
about the black church
what do you do how do you what do you do
i'm i'm a reverend right
i got all this power i'm preaching and
people come and talk to me the
beautiful ladies they're talking man
about that problem what do i do i'm just
a [ __ ] creature of life what do i do
i'm a [ __ ] human being how do i
handle that
what kind of discipline did i that i
developed from [ __ ] preaching
to handle that i don't know it depends
yeah
well you know yeah because i think they
think they
are um you know supposed to be leaders
and guiders
of a flock that's really what the church
really represents
it's like you know i'm supposed to take
the word
and then deliver it to you and so when
you have issues you come to me and i
refer back to the word to try to help
you or guide you through that
what saints and sinners does is um
speaks to your point of like well [ __ ]
i'm just human too so
how the [ __ ] you know i'm trying to help
you and now i'm i'm [ __ ] up over here
that's really what it is about the show
is about it's like
they're actually going through things
too they're suffering too
their life is in shambles too because
we're all just human
right and so we kind of touch on those
things i love that
yeah humanizing it yes yeah yeah
well you know a lot of spiritual leaders
are like
crazy you know sex addicts and
all of that stuff oh yeah you guys you
do you remember when kirk
franklin came out and said he was
addicted to
are you porn addicted to the point when
you have people worshipping you all
right and then something goes on you
since you see it touching you think
wow i'm married though but what am i
doing how did i put myself in this
situation why did you do this to me god
um yeah well you know why did you do
this or maybe it's like thank you
guys okay or thank you yeah i could be
either way but
listen it's probably more of what you
said like i think when there's an
addiction or something like that that's
pain
so i think he's saying why me why did
you make me dance so good why do you
make me so talented
now so now is the problem with him
liking himself
you know because he knows what he's
doing is wrong and he's supposed to be
representing god but what is
representing god god can represent
himself
what created god god created himself god
has ever lived
everlasting there's no beginning there's
no end
[Music]
yeah and i'm just talking about god as
we know god's
existence is energy yeah right you know
it's inconceivable what that truly is
yep yep true
but everybody's got something
everybody's got something
i was addicted to beautiful right babe
i was it makes people beautiful you know
we all hide in fear we're afraid of what
people think about it we're afraid about
our reputation
our whole existence is fear in this
world
the baddest [ __ ] on this planet
is afraid
of he may not be the baddest
[ __ ] on the planet you may find
out something about him saying
you're not the baddest [ __ ] on
the planet our secrets that we hide
yeah and then
you realize that everybody's afraid
everybody's afraid of something
yeah we're afraid of us we're afraid of
ourselves we don't know who we are we
might be
portray ourselves we don't know well
that's that speaks to that poem like the
mask right we all
wear a mask at some you know every day
we wake up we
we put on the mask that's the illusion
of ourselves yeah you know who do we
think we are
really who do we say i don't know who
the [ __ ] i am but i really think that
i'm somebody
but why do i think i'm somebody special
because i come from nothing special my
mother my father my neighborhood
there's nothing special it's really it's
the crippling i should be embarrassed to
say i'm from there but why what what
makes me think i have people the world
should see me the world shouldn't know
my name
where she even acknowledged me what the
[ __ ] made me think those are the [ __ ]
mind why do i think those that way i
hate the way i think that way
but i love the way i love the fact that
i think that way does that make sense
yes
it does yeah but what is special ma'am
like what is
what is unique it's it's all your
experience
you know these are sort of human created
ideas you know that saying brownsville
isn't a special place
it's pretty [ __ ] special and unique
man no
to me it is but to the masters of the
place you're born in that
field but that's that's a culturally
that's all i know
all of that thought is a whole
culturally created idea
how oh how could you grow up in
brownsville
you know but who are those people right
oh because what you grew up in beverly
hills you're special
[ __ ] that but you know i look at my life
and i look at my mother and father and
say how could they really think they can
raise children the lifestyle that we
lived i couldn't even dream we could
raise some kids and we could have a good
life
everything was by accident they didn't
love each other well i don't think many
people who have
kids yeah i think they know how to do
that that's a whole separate
conversation because
you know what i would think what made
them think that they could raise
children because you're supposed to
procreate live together
because you're supposed to they didn't
love each other they didn't live
together
what made them think they could raise
kids they had three kids together what
made they
live what made them think they could
have kids because you're supposed to
yeah it's ours yeah it's it's it's it's
our it's what we do it's what we're here
one of the things we're here to do
so we're vessels pretty much yes yeah
and that's why some people aren't
prepared some people are or
feel they're prepared some people kill
their kids true tea
true tea some people get what the [ __ ]
is this and they just can't handle this
i don't want that it's giving away i
don't want that
yeah you know yeah yeah
yeah so those are weird scenarios i have
in life what the hell these people were
thinking
i mean i think it's good stuff it's good
stuff you know that you're
processing you know
how did i come from like being strong
and drugs
how i get here how i get this company
and everything start working out how are
they getting married to my wife
i'm [ __ ] marriage workout for 10
years how did that how did this
how did it start how did it end up in
like this love 10 years i can't live
without you [ __ ]
because i think certain things are
destiny you guys don't believe in that
like certain things are supposed to be
and that's destiny that's what destiny
is is that you're eventually going to
find your way
to your purpose or your calling or the
people that are supposed to be in your
life that
is what destiny is you know what i mean
so yeah nobody is steering the ship but
the
the footsteps are ordered and so you're
eventually going to be where you're
supposed to be
i think that tying that back to
you know the people who get crushed by
life you know you have to be
willing to just take another step take
another step
exactly to just be in the flow and to
allow the universe's destiny for you to
unfold
exactly yeah exactly because
nothing i've ever done over the course
of my life was what i thought
it didn't go the way i thought it was
going to go it didn't happen
you know i put my plan of action you
know a plan of attack into action and
try to do
and every time i try to do what the hell
i wanted to do was [ __ ] up
and then the minute i just released you
know and just said hey
okay i'm not gonna i'm gonna have my
thought process of my goals and what i
wanna achieve
but i'm not gonna try too hard to steer
how those things
work yes get out your own way get out of
your
own way my wife said this what we're
gonna do we're gonna do this
reality we're gonna do um we're gonna
write some shows we'll do this okay okay
we're gonna do that we're gonna do that
and this is where we at we got here
there yes you know
yes i don't know how that should work
but we're here now
we gotta go on [ __ ] we got our own
[ __ ] ache we got a [ __ ] tyson
ranch
we got a whole music festival [ __ ] pool
you see it's just blowing up brother you
see what's happening
you don't have any expectations that's
that's that's it
when you don't expect anything you can't
be disappointed yeah
all you're doing is just working and
moving within the within the energy in
the space and if it happens it happens
if it doesn't it doesn't and that's when
people too much press put too much
pressure on their lives to ha
like if i left here and said [ __ ] babe i
want a tyson ranch
and i want to have be able to have room
with [ __ ] and temperatures and [ __ ]
you know the tammy ranch i want that
[ __ ] and then i start trying to work
towards that
if that's not what the [ __ ] i'm supposed
to be doing
it's never going to be this yeah you
understand what i'm saying no matter how
hard i try
oh i can't find the camera man all the
people lay i can't find a building
you know it's never gonna work out you
know so i gotta
everybody's gotta stay in their lane and
stay their course because what's meant
for you
is not necessarily meant for me and
what's meant for me is not necessarily
meant for him and so on and so forth but
the problem with society
is people come here and they look at you
and go [ __ ]
if mike got that [ __ ] i can have it too
that [ __ ] must be easy to get listen
it's true
but with a price yes
but that's what people don't know
because they're looking at just
surface yeah and they don't know the
blood sweat and tears and the cost and
everything it takes to make this work
and how
the people have to be really [ __ ] with
you and rock with you to make sure that
they show up every day to
make this [ __ ] work they don't know that
they're just looking at what's happening
on the out the gloss and glitz of it all
and that's where people [ __ ] up because
that's what they do they look at the
gloss and the glitz or the aesthetic of
something to go out just like the
[ __ ] who's getting their asses done
you look at a [ __ ] you're going [ __ ] i
want that that [ __ ] this [ __ ] has got a
2 million followers on instagram and she
getting she posting ads and [ __ ] and
getting pam give me some ass
and then the [ __ ] ended up looking like
a potato you know that wasn't your [ __ ]
to do a hundred percent you know what i
believe in stuff since i've been in the
entertainment business i consider boxing
yeah for sure yes that's the only
reality
only the people that um the people that
laughing on the top are the toughest in
the
the cold as hard as one that's used to
self-defeation and everything they just
determined to get their goal and
accomplish their goals those are the
ones that make it
mm-hmm that's what life is about you
know i mean sacrificing self
to accomplish your goals yep yeah
whatever your goals are good yeah but
you got to sacrifice yourself
yeah you gotta get out of your own head
i mean focus on that goal
mike i know this was true for me playing
football
because so many times long i hated it
you can speak to that baby i [ __ ]
hated it you know the
[ __ ] grind and the violence and man i
gotta go out here
five days a week and practice and beat
the [ __ ] out of these guys and knock
heads with these guys so i can play in a
game on sunday
when i love it and in my head i'm
aspiring to be this gladiator in this
warrior
but i [ __ ] i was just like
so many times it was just a deep
love-hate relationship
i mean but it was the universe carrying
me along
definitely big time universe saying this
is what you need to do
right now you know this is who you are
right now
and i'm sure you felt like that along
the way there's a time for that first
chance i have to go to my ego i have to
go deep and talk into my ego and say
they'll watch me forever people talk to
me talk about me forever
they named their children after me right
they get into my ego
yeah i'm a god yeah how dare them even
challenge me
yeah i know that feeling reggie you
played football yeah
awesome how uh where
hurricanes yeah i see him
right and had a little cup of coffee
with the saints
nice man and uh around that time you
know my mother had passed and whatnot
so it was kind of like just took my
drive
you know i mean to continue with it but
um
you don't want to do that with no drive
yeah man football football
my first love bro you know yeah that was
that prepared me for life absolutely
definitely did yeah i mean few
other sports where you get your ass
kicked
knocked down and you have to get up
every play you know and do it again
i love that dude the you who are you
there with man i was there from 2005.
my last year was oh so greg olsen
oh my god
beast mayweather is in the pros now
right oh yeah
a lot of these guys all these guys are
in the league were you there
dj was dj williams a little early
i played with dj in chicago i love tj
arizona i was at arizona from
i was there from 05 to 08. oh okay
so clarence's yeah he was before me
yeah oh awesome yeah he was a beast
i met him at a golf tournament yeah
that's awesome man well yeah i mean you
know
you just got to let the universe take
you where you need to go
yeah what do you want to do when this is
all over and it's done what do you want
to say boom this is what i did what do
you want to accomplish
i think i'm meant to be in the
entertainment space
i think um i want to be able to put out
like now i'm forging into producing and
executive producing
so for me content-wise to be able to
leave something that
you know a little emmy hell yeah girl
little emmy you know emmy when
you know things like that i think when
anybody produces content they want
it to be recognized you know because
they put their hard work into it you
know what i mean so
i where my my projects
made people think gave someone a voice
that's that's what i'm into right now
yeah
that's what i'm into i love that i love
that
what do you what kind of stuff you think
about producing
i like scripted yeah um so i want to
like tell the stories
of of my neighborhood you know like
where i grew up you know
um because i grew up in some hard [ __ ]
yeah
drugs and you know family issues and
things of that nature putting
you know stuff out there like that yeah
yeah
that's not that's not hollywood
hollywood eyes
yeah which is not a word but you know
just
just made up i think i think the
the the projects like um
you know from days of old uh
uh color purple you know like where
the real story was told and it wasn't
glamorized you know for for public
consumption it was like the real story
like i would like tv to return
back to that you know absolutely that's
a
there's a great opportunity for that
yeah yeah i think it is
yeah but i'll probably do another
reality show where it's six [ __ ]
fighting
that's the people want to see but
basketball wise who's the main
troublemaker
uh at one point it was me
spanish girl the girl is with um ochocho
ochocinco yes she has her moments you
know i think
over the course of the show we've all
done some [ __ ] and been in some
shenanigans you know what i'm saying
so uh we've all taken a turn there
really is no one person we've all taken
a turn describe
the basketball wives like when you look
up when you see them on television when
you're objective
when you look at how do you describe
them what do you like if i wasn't on it
no just being i'm taking a look outside
looking in
yeah um
i don't it's it's mindless entertainment
i don't really get anything from
watching our show because the way our
show is designed
it's it's not formatted for that you
know what i mean
i think you get a lot of you get a
really interesting perspective of
humanity
i don't know i don't not at all i see
jealousy i do yeah i see a lot of it's
like a psychological experiment
however i don't know shame there
if if if that were true
then i would have to say everyone has
would have to have been
authentic and genuine in the moment and
i can't necessarily say that i believe
some of these women are telling their
real story
do i hear that beef one of those what's
the name again
that i'm always beefing with yeah what's
her name come on you just said her
no that's suspect you don't know you
don't know
cause i don't say her name so like so
then there
even that thing of not being authentic
i think is fascinating that we've
created this
vehicle in our society where people
feel inclined to go and be something
i think that's really fascinating when
you can tell when people
are [ __ ] just putting on a show
trying to you know i don't know
trying to be something you know i think
that's really interesting that there's
this whole
thing going on and it's about you know
your presence in the digital
world in many ways what are we hiding
though
everything yeah i think i think people
are people are hiding everywhere i think
people are hiding stuff
because they're ashamed of themselves
they'll think oh somebody's gonna find
out i was a [ __ ] nerd in high school
or you know i was abused or i'm not good
enough you know because we have this
like
thing that we're not worthy and that's
why i tell it
exactly you gotta just be
but that's the brilliance of being human
you know and that's when you're real and
honest
that's when people's lives get touched
man
you know we had this we had chris cyborg
on okay the last strong
female we had in here and
i'm telling it was it was one of our
heaviest episodes
and mike was going through a lot and i
[ __ ] burst into tears
wow and i haven't received
more positive messages from guys being
like dude that episode changed my life
seeing you guys open up to each other
and that
what you guys were saying i was in tears
yeah yeah and it's just like yeah
because that's people feel the real
emotion
you know like you're saying i mean
you're gonna have a shift in your
consciousness
through those emotions when you're
seeing
real and authentic and authentic yeah
it's entertaining when you see someone
putting on a show
right and it's an interesting thing that
people feel the need to do that
i think so that's what i'm saying i
think that you know
that's important i just think that's
interesting i yeah [ __ ] man
i'm not gonna tell you what shows i
watch because that's embarrassing
what do you watch i want to know now i
want to know what bothers you some of
the real housewives
okay that that's a great show my wife
says
and atlanta yeah the no they're all good
um
that's the so i can't i can't do
i make him watch them all you know i
make him watch atlanta
how's it interesting
who we are as people it's yeah who we
are i know all those people not by name
it's the buddies know all that spirits i
just know people like you yeah yeah for
my life
mm-hmm yeah yeah yeah
absolutely well i don't know tammy is
there anything else you want to shout
out before we get out of here
uh no movies coming up no what's your
daughter doing
i have two daughters and so one is uh
these daughters
yeah they're both kenny's yeah yes i am
but i was not laying it low and
threatening wide and [ __ ] everything
moving sorry i didn't mean that
but come on the one i've seen on the
show with you both of them have been on
the show with me one's a rapper
one's arrested this one no the oldest
one uh
is my academic she's my she's my person
tell me about the rapper yeah the
rapper's the youngest one but the
tallest one which is why you thought she
was the oldest but uh
she uh she's doing her music thing you
know she's trying to make it pop and all
that
um you watched the deal she has a
distribution deal with empire
yeah but she's still independent she's
an empire that's the
a huge distribution arm that puts out
content yeah they got fat joe
and remy ma okay cool yeah yeah so yeah
yeah so she's working on it grinding on
it
you know you know you feel good you're
shopping enough you love
life how's everything going everything
is going good i mean i've really
been married uh one year one year yeah
our anniversary is coming up august 17th
that's beautiful yeah but we were
together for five
four years and now our wedding our
marriage makes five years
totally nice yeah yeah but everything is
good you know i can't complain and
nobody would care anyway that's the
thing people don't
realize it's like well sure i got my own
[ __ ] going on so i want to hear your
[ __ ] too
but everything's good people care people
care
like oh interesting i don't know because
i i typically
you know honestly don't want to hear it
sometimes like i really do be having my
own [ __ ] and so when you call me with
your [ __ ] then i feel like oh god now i
got the weight of your [ __ ] and my [ __ ]
well i think that's healthy but
you know in our mind our world is really
big but really you we could probably
count on i've told us
how many people we really know and to
act to it
but we think our world is big it's big
yeah yeah yeah i have a small circle i
keep it small for a purpose
yeah yeah you guys gonna be voting right
let's just go ahead and get that out of
the way
okay just making sure it's just always
sure one vote for what
president president
[Laughter]
you better be there
you're going to be there we're not
listening
it's like definitely definitely
mike is this is going to be good because
that's a serious
huh are you a democrat no i'm a micah
i'm a minecraft a monkey a micah
okay i got it independent i don't like
love i don't like um
[ __ ] labels and stuff yeah you know
[ __ ] the labels man well we do
understand i just want to make sure that
we do understand
did you vote for trump [ __ ] no okay
cause the way you paused i was like oh
lord y'all
no okay so we getting him out no [ __ ]
man i mean i i don't know yeah i mean
it's
i'm a little nervous but i'm excited
any thoughts on the abortion bill that
was just
tell me about that what happened well
certain states uh
have taken away a woman's right to
choose yeah that's horrendous
wrong it's awful it's absurd that in
2019 we're even we're even having this
conversation prehistoric
yeah that we're having this conversation
which speaks to like
how you said earlier in the conversation
there are women who are having children
and they don't know what to do with them
and some of them are
you know god forbid killing them because
they're not ready so now you're going to
force them
to have it yeah you know what i mean so
i just feel like you're someone
else i haven't been to atlanta because
they're one of the states
georgia is one of the states that uh is
uh
you know entertaining it's just
fascinating yeah
it's fascinating that we feel a need to
these people feel and need to control
that
exactly and they're men it's demented
that it's men who are passing this
you know when they don't really even
understand what it's like to carry a
child
to have that responsibility because you
know what most of y'all
true not you not true but most of y'all
gets in the [ __ ] wind
and then we are the ones who you know
are are
there for the rest of that child's life
still in darkness
true tea life is still in darkness yeah
and i didn't really
sometimes you don't know you're in
darkness until you're in the light so
you're in the light
[Music]
yeah and that's basically what they're
saying it's insane
[ __ ] [ __ ] i feel like if if the
woman has to keep the child
then the man who raped her or
if we're talking rape you need to be
castrated if i have to keep this child
then the father there needs to be child
support laws
put into place as well that are standard
primary focused so that i'm now going to
have this kid
then you also have to contribute and pay
for it if you're not going to be here
you know what i mean i don't believe in
that i believe um this is a government
problem the government should take care
of that kid
and the people should be taxed to take
care of that kid if they want to have
that
type of law well wait a minute wait a
minute now you said the people should be
taxed this kid is born if this kid is
born the father when we take care of it
and something she's just left out there
and she can't take care that we have to
take care of that kid who's we might
a society our society the government we
have to be taxed
i don't want to be taxed for people's
other people's
children i think you should have the you
should have the freedom to have an
abortion if you don't want to have a
child
exactly she said she had the child
though you usually get one like
like now yeah like if they passed the
law hypothetically
so we're all i don't want to be taxed
anymore because we're already being
taxed and a lot
everything that comes out of people's
checks it's like these are the [ __ ]
complaining about people on welfare
it's like what are you talking about
it's gonna be more people on welfare
exactly
exactly why like so what is that
twisted [ __ ] it's power trying to
have power trying to have control it's a
it's
an ego trip and i think welfare is good
till you get your job
yes you should have one welfare support
till you get your job you get your job
but there needs to be something that
says you got to get you got to go get a
job
right in a certain amount of time
six months [ __ ]
you cut off and then you gotta deal with
some prison time probably you got six
months to find some work
anything yeah just pay the bills i agree
with you and who am
but you got to do something you got to
put a fire into somebody to give them
that [ __ ] enthusiasm
with enthusiasm everything comes in play
you just have to have enthusiasm yeah
yeah you know people goes the word one
with me i gotta go back to the [ __ ]
white man job
you know not serious though really
but then that you know that's another
deprogramming because
you should be going to get going to work
at something you love
yeah but that's not always the case i
know i know but how do people get to
that
they sacrifice so you have to work that
shitty job until you can
get to a place where you can do the
stuff you want to do live on the street
until you get the
right job if you don't want to do the
shitty job you live on the streets until
you get the right job
yeah i don't know either man i don't
know
we had that guy remember that guy andres
pira
oh he was awesome the homeless guy
became the billionaire yeah he was
homeless on the beach in thailand
and he just he now he's a billionaire
real estate mogul
wow and he um he said that
he got his hands on this book called the
secret
you know the book and he was like this
is [ __ ] this isn't real
and so but he was like as an experiment
to prove i'm gonna try
yeah i'm gonna do what it said he said i
started with envisioning a cup of coffee
because i hadn't had coffee and
god knows how long he said i just
imagined this cup of coffee i
felt it in my hand i imagined what it
smelled like and tasted like
imagine the feeling of it and he was
like
two days later some dude walking on the
beach
came up to him and gave him a cup of
coffee he was like
what and then he just kept going he was
like okay well and then he was like i'm
gonna go get a job and he [ __ ]
envisioned a job and then he got a job
and then
that's what happened to me here same
thing happened to me here i was in here
talking to him
and i said um [ __ ] i say this [ __ ] i
don't know
i said you know what i want to get into
the tobacco business put some cbd in a
tobacco and get some synthetic
synthesize some tobacco or something
next thing you know we get a call from
british tobacco wow
wow oh yeah i met those guys ain't that
crazy it's crazy
we thought them up it's thought them up
that's right i didn't know about bridges
to do cbd cigarettes yeah oh well [ __ ]
where is that y'all
we'll get you some timmy no no no no no
we're not going to do that because they
don't want to be in the tobacco business
no they want to be in the
um no yeah that too but uh edible what's
that [ __ ] that you smoke
vape is right they don't want no more
combustibles
so the cigarettes are getting ready to
become history and the vapes are going
to become
i don't i don't think so i don't think
that either but i don't think so
that's what that was the smoking is kind
of an it's an ancient
thing i think mostly i don't think
smoking is everything
it's never going to go away most of the
main addiction is it's a habit
yeah it's a ritual yeah it's not going
anywhere so just going to put that cbd
on up in there
because it's not going anywhere
it's coming listen we have no idea
what's going to happen in the future we
have no idea
sure no i [ __ ] ain't doing it yeah
but i know somebody
there's a new plant there's going to be
there's new minerals that's going to be
in the future
you know so i used to know the future is
really crazy
yeah that's for sure
it is man look at all these new look at
the business look at all these new
billionaires look at all these people
coming
look at us coming up this is crazy how
does that happen so fast
because it's supposed to yeah it's
supposed to have yeah it's divine
yeah you know it's all in alignment
so it just [ __ ] goes five minutes now
y'all got five minutes ah well i'm good
awesome
well why don't you tell everybody where
they can find you uh
instagram twitter
all tammy roman t-a-m-y roman
we do not you're going to have anything
um
how do i answer that we've tried we had
three miscarriages
yes and so i just felt like i wasn't
going to put my body through that
anymore
uh so we may get a surrogate okay don't
do it
because he doesn't have any kids my wife
had more kids i wanted to have more
you want to have more yeah yeah i have
more with her
yeah i would love to have his
you know baby i mean it's like we gave
it our best shot and so now we got the
eggs on ice
and we're gonna you know have someone
else yeah but you know you're gonna be
ready
you gotta be ready yeah yeah that's
beautiful too man
that we're in that age yes yeah it's
like oh
here girl carry this for me i won't be
able to make it
the planet one day our grandkids may be
on another planet
yeah so much is possible yeah everything
so much as possible
well thank you so much thank you so much
thank you so much you're the man dude
thank you so much
immensely absolute pleasure mike great
convo
i think this is an awesome show hey what
happened to your cousin i used to go out
with
well i was going to act like i didn't
know nothing about that because i felt
like you was acting like you didn't know
nothing about that so i was just gonna
mind my business
uh i on the show with y'all one time yes
very very long time ago
she didn't like that [ __ ] she said this
ain't my [ __ ] yeah she's a very long
time ago but um
yeah i haven't talked to should i can i
say her name yes
no i haven't talked to shauna maybe in
five years
five years five six years yeah you just
lose contact
ten years and then you don't talk to him
yeah we lost contact and i haven't seen
her
but i was i was telling kiki i was like
i've given mike a lot of money
i've i've given mike a lot of money over
the years like i was at
all the [ __ ] fights like i paid top
dollar for my front row feet i was
balling back
how was that like back then when you
were born we had a lot of friends back
then
of course that's how it is you know
that's how it
everybody's with you when you when you
ball in yeah that's for sure
famous husband and she yeah yeah yeah
that's true he said he was bowling yeah
balling yeah i was bullied these were
crazy
it was it was such a good time late 80s
90s like it's my favorite
you know my favorite era it was just
good for other reasons than because i
was balling but just like it was just a
good time
you know but yeah totally gonna make you
believe like when you lived in the 80s
and 90s so much time
you didn't think you were gonna die
you're gonna live forever yep incredible
yeah that's true that's true yeah
world domination [ __ ]
boom dead i love it that's it the final
word hey everybody
thanks for watching this episode of hot
boxing
i'm evan britt mike tyson tammy roman
peace that was awesome
it was really good
[Music]
[Music]